okay this is uh i don't know if this is
surprising or it's not surprising
but we have another audio leak of donald
trump
pressuring georgia officials to find
him the votes that he needs donald
trump's call
to the investigator came several days
before
the call with georgia secretary of state
brad raffensberger
you'll remember in the past we had
leaked audio of trump on the phone with
raffensberger and others
saying i just need 11 780 votes
this new audio is from a different call
where uh it was a few days prior to the
raffensberger call
donald trump is on the phone with
francis watson
who's the chief investigator in the
georgia
secretary of state's office we are going
to listen to it i'm realizing i don't
even have my headphone in so let me put
that in so i can listen to it along with
you
and i'm getting all of my cables all
wound up here let's take a listen
together
all right new call okay new call
let's uh take a listen to this here we
go
and uh let's make sure we aren't muted
and off we go all right
let's take a listen uh it's very
interesting so i won florida in a record
number ohio and a record texas at a
record
right alabama by 40 40 points and i won
everything but georgia and
i you know and i won george i know that
by a lot and
i won jojo by a lot he says people know
it
and you know something happened there i
mean
something bad happened and i hope you
enjoyed that uh
that because if you you know i hope
you're going back
in two years as opposed to just checking
you know one against the other because
that would just be sort of
a a signature check that didn't mean
anything but
if you go back two years and if you can
get to fulton
you're going to find things that are
going to be unbelievable the dishonesty
that we've heard from them right you
know just good sources
really good sources but fulton is the
mother lode you know as the expression
goes
fulton county all right uh
mr president yeah i want to speak right
yeah i
i i appreciate your comments and and i
i i can assure you that our team and
the gbi that we're only interested in in
the truth
and and finding you know finding the
information that's based on the facts
and you know we we've been working um 12
16 hour days
and you know we're working through trump
likes that we're
working for what exactly is not clear
but through it and
um so i can assure you that and
i do appreciate you calling i know that
you're a very very busy very important
man and and i'm very honored that that
you called
and you know and quite important what
you're doing quite um
quite frankly i i'm shocked and that you
you would take time to do that but well
he's trying to steal an election right i
mean
this is his last he thinks he needs this
he thinks you're great and you know it's
just you have the most important job in
the country right now because
if we win georgia first of all if we win
you're gonna have two wins
they're not gonna win right now you know
they're down because
the people of georgia are so angry at
what happened to me they know i won
one by hundreds of thousands of votes so
now trump is not even claim remember
later
it seems that between this call and the
next call he he goes he
here he believes he won by hundreds of
thousands and maybe he even thinks that
there would be
something done by these officials to
give him such a big win
within days clearly his perspective has
changed because he's just talking about
i just need eleven thousand eleven seven
eighty
and his his expectations are tempered by
the next call
and alabama you know where they i won uh
south carolina and a record
alabama and a record florida and a
record imagine calling an official in
georgia and just bragging about your
wins in other states as if that has
anything to do with what
this woman's job is here i want florida
by 600
i think he only won florida by a couple
hundred thousand like everything is a
lie an exaggeration
and uh with all the money they spent you
know you heard all these guys going down
spending a fortune and we won texas by a
record
texas was won by the biggest biggest
number ever
and it you know it didn't it didn't and
and ohio of course you know that you
know about that that was one
by nine points he's the president and
he's bragging to a county
uh a state uh official in georgia
about his margins in other states this
is the president of the united states
calling this person and bragging in this
way
all of it iowa
it never made sense and you know
they dropped ballots they dropped all
these ballots
stacey abrams really really terrible i
mean just a terrible thing
registering people to vote getting
people out it's horrible what she did
i will say this if it went home i mean
hopefully
this will show because if you go back
two years or four years it's a totally
different signature but hopefully
uh i you know i will when when
the right answer comes out you'll be
praised i mean
when you'd give us the right answer
francis which is that i won
people will love don't know why you know
they've made it so hard
they will be praised people will say
great
because that's what it's about that
ability to check into
and to make it right because everyone
knows it's wrong there's just no way
you know they had people in georgia for
instance that won
and i was way ahead of them and they won
because of me and i pulled them
they call it coattails right and so this
went on for four more minutes and it's
just
more trump insisting he won and to her
credit francis watson doesn't really
concede much
at all we then just have as a reminder
the clips from the previous call
uh which uh with the previous call which
we
actually which took place later the
later call which we learned about some
time ago
here's one clip from that the people of
georgia are angry the people of the
country are angry
and there's nothing wrong with saying
that you know uh
that you've recalculated because uh
the 2336 and absentee ballots i mean
they're all exact numbers that were were
done by
accounting firms law firms etc and even
if you cut them in half cut them in half
and cut them in half
again it's more votes than we need
well mr president the challenge that you
have is the data you have is wrong
right say we've recalculated 2200
ballots it's enough for us to win
uh and that was that was brad
raffensberger telling trump that his
data was simply wrong
on that call trump continued making
false statements
trying to convince them to find votes
claiming he won by hundreds of thousands
bringing up more conspiracy theories i
won this election by hundreds of
thousands of votes
there's no way i lost georgia there's no
way we won by hundreds of thousands of
votes
i'm just going by small numbers when you
add them up there many times the eleven
thousand but but i won that state by
hundreds of thousands of us
now do you think it's possible that they
uh shredded
ballots in uh fulton county because
that's what the rumor is
and also that dominion took out machines
uh that dominion is really moving fast
to get rid of their
uh machinery do you know anything about
that
because that's illegal ryan germany no
dominion has not um
moved any machinery out of fulton county
we're having well but no but but if they
move
have they have they moved the inner
parts of the machines
and replaced them with other parts
no he's your ryan
i'm sure i'm sure mr president what
about what about the uh
what about the ballots the shredding of
the ballasts have they been shredding
ballots
no the only investigation that we have
into that they have not been shredding
any ballots
there was an issue in cobb county where
they were doing normal
uh you know office shredding getting rid
of old stuff
and we investigated that so trump just
desperately grasping at straws and then
remember that in the end even if he had
somehow flipped georgia
it wouldn't have made a difference
because it would not have been enough
electoral votes just one more clip from
the old phone call
which happened after the one we learned
about today trump suggesting that this
is actually bad for georgia officials
they might be liable if they don't find
a way for trump to get the win
the ballots are corrupt and you're going
to find that they are which is totally
illegal it's
it's it's more illegal for you than it
is for them because you know what they
did and you're not reporting it that's a
you know that's a criminal that's a
criminal offense
and and you know you can't let that
happen that's that's a big risk
to you and to riot your lawyer that's a
big risk
all i want to do is this i just want to
find
uh 11 780
votes so trump there kind of implicitly
threatening the lawyers and officials
if you let it happen you could be you
could be criminally liable
so a totally criminal bully president
another recording
from another conversation coming out
almost two months post-trump
leaving office what will we know in
another month what will we know
in a month after that what we are
learning is that the authoritarians who
tried to overthrow the election
were far more brazen than we previously
thought i don't think we've come even
close
to hearing it all yet and when all is
said and done the biggest evidence
is probably yet to come they're getting
access to emails and texts
which will give us the context and
planning like this call these two calls
they don't just happen there's likely a
paper trail
about how this call came to be and about
the intentions for these calls
and we may eventually learn about that
we'll have more coverage of this on the
show instagram at david pakman show and
make sure you're
following me on instagram at
david.pakman
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea
of going into a doctor's office right
now and thankfully
there is a practical and affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz see which doctor is right for
you
i took their quiz they matched me with a
doctor who specializes in my particular
health needs and situation the doctor
they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video